yeah so fast yep yep the information
paradox you said it's like falling in
love with holography and that the
entropy inside a black hole can be
different than the outside so can you
explain what you mean by that
yes um
right now in the uh
community of physicists
uh there's been a a a separation between
two communities which have completely
different opinions
about the uh black hole paradox
one community it's convinced that
there's a problem
the problem it's uh
uh before quantum gravity so before the
end of the evaporation
and the problem is due to the fact that
the black hole shrinks and people are
convinced
that the number of states of the black
hole
um it's bound by the area
uh by the pakistan
[Music]
hawking entropy
and therefore uh the problem is that the
state outside seems to be um
thermal
and
in pure state
and
for that to be possible to save
unitarity
uh information should be somewhere
and the only place where it could be
reasonably inside the black hole but
there are not enough states inside the
black hole
because of
horizon has shrunk and this has
created a huge a huge problem
and
there are
complicated solutions which have been
studied today and people are sort of
getting convinced that this complicated
solution of the the way out
the other half of the community
which are most relativist and not
particle physics and people like me um
just don't believe this story absolutely
because to create this paradox you have
to believe quantum mechanics which is
unitarian we all expect quantum
mechanics to be unity you have to
believe uh uh
that
generativity holds and some
reasons where we don't expect one to
gravity and
many of us expect that and you have to
believe an additional assumption
which is the number of black hole states
inside the black hole it's bound by the
area
and that
has no strong ground
people got in love with the idea
because there are calculations that
allow you to describe black hole in
terms of a final number of states bound
by the area but this is a description
uh
of what you see from the outside
as long as the horizon is an event
risers horizon forever
and the horizon black hole is not an
eventualization because at some point
the black hole becomes very small
something happens
and at that point it may very well be
that the big information which is
outside comes out
okay
and the confusion the subtle confusion
here
it's that uh people
uh is used to say
that the phenomenon entropy is bounded
by the thermodynamical entropy namely
phenomena entropy is in the the the
the amount of information due to the
entanglement between the inside two
things
at the terminal entropy
count the number of state if you
interact terminally with something and
people say well of course for neumann
and to be it's bounded by the
thermodynamical entropy because the
thermodynamic entry count a number will
see it if you don't have this state you
cannot have fun
for normal entropy but that's wrong
because uh
if one part of of the interior system
is thermally disconnected you can still
have a big volume and entropy and a
decreasing thermodynamical entropy and
that's exactly what happened in black
holes
and
people who are sort of blinded by
over excessive
taking a strong version of holography
just don't see that very basic point
and don't see that if you give a full
description
that include what happened after the end
of the evaporation you can have a
phenomenon to be much larger than the
thermodynamic enterprise simply talking
the whole of the black hole shrinks
becomes smaller and smaller and smaller
where the backhoe evaporates
but the inside remains very big there's
a lot of information there
which is not lost
where the black hole ends the
evaporation when you say the inside
remember slowly comes out the inside of
yeah
the black hole
the black hole has a it's like a throat
yeah the horizon and then there is an
inside which is very very big that's the
point i mean you can have a very very
big spatial
space like surfaces are huge
okay and that's where the information is
and at the end of evaporation now we're
in quantum gravity and with loop quantum
gravity you can do calculation to what
happened
and you there's there's a quantum
transition to a region in which the
inside is still there and slowly it
leaks out all the information
so i think that there's a
perfectly
coherent picture
uh which shows that it's not true
that there's a black hole information
problem
the belief in the black hole information
problem
is based on a
a dogma
uh has become a dogma which is not
supported by by anything
that the
uh the number of states of black hole
computer from the outside also include
the information inside in popular
science you always hear that when
someone falls into the black hole you
won't see them
well you'll see them freeze right at the
horizon
and there you'll see their watch frozen
too now if the black hole event yeah
yeah
this is
we don't know that because that's the
benefit of gravity see that's that's
exactly the that's exactly the problem
uh
when time goes on
okay you see what you see somebody is
crossing the black hole
so the person crosses black hole of
course crosses it like oh i mean nothing
particular happened crossing the horizon
just normal
normal time going back
but the light rays that it emits
uh gets to you
later and later and later and later okay
now if the horizon is an eventerizer so
if the horizon stays there forever yeah
you can go to infinity and you only see
the person before crossing
but we don't know in fact the the
horizon is not element right the rise
does not go to infinity because at some
point the black hole becomes plunkin and
that's where in quantum gravity and when
in quantum gravity there is a quantum
transition
after which
the information outside can go outside
okay so if you wait long enough
you see inside the black hole
interesting that's the point
interesting okay next one do you find
that your ability to learn let's say
math and physics has increased with age
or decreased
decreased decreased much decreased i
when i was in my 20s i could take
a complicated mathematically complicated
paper just sit down on a chair and
read it through and i would get
everything easily
and then it slowly became more
complicated and now in my 60s i struggle
i go slow i read less papers so my
capacity to learn is decreasing
and also
i think my flexibility
of thinking is going down i tend to know
much more things before i have much more
developed views before i know more
things
i see when other people are wrong
because i know things they don't know
it's happened much more often than
before i mean it's easy to see the
mistakes of the others because because i
know more things everybody getting cold
or no small things so that's why all the
people why is it but also
i am more stupid because i'm more
trapped in my own thinking i have more
difficulty of coming out for my home
thinking
what would you have done differently in
the development of your theory it could
be as simple as i would have spent more
time going for walks with lee than
sitting down or i would have spent more
time thinking about
about holography like ads cft
correspondence for whatever reason or
you would have spent less time arguing
with your peers like what is it that you
would have done differently in the
development of your current theories
um
there have been situations in which uh
people have raised objections
to things i've done
uh i got convinced that these objections
were wrong
and i just ignored
that and just
don't didn't bother respond
and
i
i don't think i should have paid more
attention to the objections because i
did always pay very much attention to
the objection that i read around
but i think it was a mistake not to
respond and not to immediately sit down
and try to argue in detail
i
i probably overestimated myself and uh
and in the field as a whole
thinking oh come on i think that's wrong
and people will figure out by themselves
i i
i try not to engage in debates
and uh and discussions
um
and and go my own way and something
sometimes works very well
but sometimes has
you know created long misunderstanding
so i should have
more engaged with with criticism trying
to respond and be more
more
more more
uh
part of the group and just debating with
the group
okay this question comes from stefan
alexander he's a professor of
theoretical physics and i know he's a
great guy great great he's the writer of
fear of black universe fear of a black
universe and the link to that is in the
description also i'll be speaking with
stefan so that's either out or coming up
how does time play into quantum gravity
you've mentioned it plays into quantum
mechanics does it play into quantum
gravity per se
um
it does not
i think that's uh uh that's the bottom
line also my book once you go to quantum
gravity
uh you better forget entirely
the the word time
just forget about it
you have a bunch of variables
which describe the gravitational field
and the thermogenetic field whatever
fields are around whatever is
it's it's your
ingredients as far as we know today
these are the ingredients of the world
electrons quarks electromagnetic field
gravitation
and you have
relations
between these
which you think in terms of
there is a quantum region
if you want a space-time region
and and outside if if i if i see
something
around what is the probability of seeing
that
and you don't have to say
uh how much time has passed which one is
a time variable
that comes out naturally
because
if the classical limit of the amplitudes
turn out to be correct they just give
generativity so in the classical limit
you have space times evolving and then
you can you know
time is just whatever passes around the
time like gold line but in the
fundamental quantum gravity theory just
forget about time entirely don't talk
about that
time has in the various meaning in which
we
we talk about them
uh
it's just something that happens at
later approximations the space time
comes at the large scale approximation
and oriented time comes from the
thermodynamics in quantum gravity the
only temporal notion it's very weak is
that you describe process so what you
describe is a process
a
a probability amplitude of some
conjunction of variables
uh taking certain values
okay this question comes from bernardo
castro
he says carlos says that everything is
relational you may have answered this
before but carlos says everything is
relational nothing absolute i agree that
the physical that is whatever is
measured is relational as experiments
have shown
but that must mean that there is an
absolute some non-physical
non-measurable layer of reality
underlying the physical
as you know
he's putting this in brackets as you
know to me that layer is mental
but carlo again says everything is
relational so
what is it relations and and so on and
so on that is turtles all the way down
or relationships all the way down how
does the notion
that everything is relational not lead
to an infinite regress
it's turtle salted way down in my
opinion
and i think what uh what burn uh i mean
i i think the basic uh
i mean i know of course uh
bananas uh
uh
uh um ideas
he defended a very strong version of
idealism
in which
everything is mental
and
i think that the mental phenomena
are
not more
absolute more grounded
more
basic more universal than
the
the physical what we call the physical
phenomena
in fact i think if
if there is a
dependence relation the dependence
relation is other way around
so
um
if one understand mental phenomena
we understand them better
starting from physical facts and from
that deriving mental phenomena
the other way around doesn't work in my
opinion the other way around leaves us
the impossibility of doing science we
don't derive physical phenomena from
mental phenomena but the other way
around we do
so of the two
uh
physical in a large sense
uh i don't mean material i'm in physics
systems interacting hypothesis
more fundamental in sense of the ground
better
mental phenomena i think the
the mistake of idealism is to
don't see
one of the main insight
um
[Music]
in uh
in
in buddhist philosophy which is that the
the mental is as illusory
buddhist language just external world so
the self is us
left um
less
founded
as this glass or this pen
when i think about myself the illusion
of this is the cartesian illusion this
is evident
this is immediate this cannot be
discounted it's wrong
um
if there's anything what is evident for
me is this pen it's not me then me it's
a complicated cultural construct social
construct cultural construct
what i directly know about the world is
that there is this pen
uh
if you say well there is also you in the
world i say oh yeah it's also me and
what is me i have to i have to do so a
reflection
a story of thinking and if you read the
card
with the roger this idea
the card never said
that um
the self
it's immediate
he said if you start doubting then you
go through a complicated cultural
process of doubting
which is due to his culture his
philosophy is
and this leads him
to thinking about the self and they
think if i'm doubting them and thinking
if i'm thinking there should be
something thinking this is thinking the
self but the something thinking is not
the self it's a symbol of the processes
that matter does in my brain
so that's why i disagree with the idea
it is
why is it that the mental states and the
self are are they equivalent in your
mind in your mind are they no they're
two different things no they're two
different things uh of course they're
two different things the self is a it's
a it's uh um
let's let me not define the self uh
there's nothing sure states is uh other
than men but i think that
um
what i said applied to both
and of course
the card was talking about the self uh
some people talk about mental state in
the in
um i think both are
like chairs
complicated construction we use to
describe
what happens
you